- All right y'all,
(audience clapping)
let's take a look at what's trending
on social media that's
sure to make us smile,
this is what I'm liking.
(lively segment music)
For Floridians finding an alligator
in your backyard doesn't happen
often though it does happen.
But if you're new to the state,
that moment can be a
complete shock (chuckles)
Of course,
Um, it's an alligator.
Just check out how this military veteran
and dad of seven girls reacted
when he had his first
encounter on his own driveway.
(swooshing sound)
(indistinguishable)
(bleep) (bleep) (bleep)
(trash can lid swinging)
(alligator banging against trash can)
(bleep) (bleep) (bleep)
(cheering)
- What?
(audience clapping)
Here's my first thought,
my first thought is of course
he can take on an alligator,
he's living with seven
daughters (chuckles)
So...
(audience laughs)
And my second thought is "Nope" (laughs)
Ah, okay,
So authorities wouldn't
recommend that method,
but thankfully it did work
out and no one was harmed,
in the removal of that, that Gator,
the guy even returned the
creature to the nearby
(Kelly laughs)
(audience laughs)
the nearby...
(indistinguishable)
"we're taking the trash out".
We have this reptile rescue...
(Kelly laughs)
(audience laughs)
I have never seen the end, oh my God
Oh (bleep), okay,
we have this, he was like (screams)
We have this reptile rescuer
on the line now watching
on our partner station WFTV
channel nine at 10:00 am.
What's up, Eugene?
(audience cheers)
(Kelly laughs)
- [Kelly] Oh my gosh
I gotta be honest with you, I
never got through to the end,
that was so funny.
So you, you only moved to
Florida a year ago, right?
So this was your first
time seeing a gator, right?
- [Eugene] It was my first
encounter with a large gator,
I've seen small ones around
and my daughter came and got me finally
and said "Dad there's a alligator outside"
so I thought it was a small one again,
when I came outside it was real big,
and the first thing I think,
let me just get closer
to see how big it is,
that's when it start hissing,
I looked at the trash can,
I said (indistinguishable)
recycling bin, we'll take him there.
So I got the recycling bin
(Kelly laughs)
and didn't hesitate,
I walked up to him with the mouth open,
and once I got close enough,
like I'm a real hippo
I just snatched him up inside of it ,
he was inside,
and I took it down to the
bottom, to the bottom of the, um
where he live at
he went back to his natural habitat.
- [Kelly] Oh my God, I mean you, okay.
Also good luck,
(audience claps)
Seven girls under one roof,
that's a lot of estrogen,
woo,
(Kelly laughs)
you're like Gator is nothing
(audience laughs)
Well, thank you so much, Eugene,
I'm liking your post right now, right?
(ting)
(audience cheers)
- [Eugene] I appreciate that.
- All right
(audience cheers)
and Eugene that is not all
(audience cheers and claps)
our season long partner Pilot Pen
the go to pen of The Kelly Clarkson show
wants to honor ultimate
overachievers just like you, man.
So they'll be using their G2 gelling pen
to write you a check
for a thousand dollars,
how's that sound?
(audience cheers)
- [Kelly] Yes!